Палаючі автомобілі, вандалізм у Тріумфальній арці,
розтрощені вітрини, сльозогінний газ проти демонстрантів.
Після трьох хвиль брутальних протестів у Франції
про рух "жовтих жилетів" дізнався майже весь світ.
Незадоволення викликала політика Макрона в галузі довкілля,
а саме - підвищення податків на пальне, зокрема екологічного.
Це вдарило по найбідніших жителях провінції, які залежать від автомобілів.
Таких, як Прісциллія.
- Ми протестуємо, бо в нас дедалі менше грошей у гаманці.
Податок на пальне - чудовий приклад.
Він і так дуже високий, а його ще більше підвищують.
Прісциллія Людоскі продає косметику, і автомобіль потрібен їй для роботи.
Та їздити на ньому жінці вже не по кишені.
Як і багатьом жителям провінції.
Тому кілька місяців тому жінка оприлюднила в мережі
петицію за зменшення податку на пальне.
Усього за кілька тижнів петицію підписали сотні тисяч людей.
А нині вже майже мільйон французів приєдналися до руху проти політики
президента Еммануеля Макрона.
Жовтий жилет - це символ їхнього протесту.
- Мені 70 років, і це мій перший протест.
Ціни зросли на все: на бензин, на газ, на електроенергію.
Мені не вистачає двохсот євро на місяць,
а моя пенсія зросла всього на три євро.
І до чого це призведе? А мій робочий стаж - сорок два роки!
- Наприкінці місяця в нас просто закінчуються гроші!
Діти недоїдають. Це нормально?
Багато людей, що гуляють набережною Сени в Парижі,
не розуміють цього занепокоєння.
Життя в центрі столиці - інакше.
Тут багато хто вважає: це добре, що Макрон хоче щось зробити
для довкілля та підвищує екологічні податки.
- Щодо руху "жовтих жилетів": у нас немає автівки і ми не хочемо її мати.
Тому цей податок нас узагалі не стосується.
Податки на дизельне пальне стали темою гострих політичних дискусій.
Французи з невеликими доходами, що живуть переважно у провінції,
не згодні з цим курсом. Прем'єр-міністр
ще нещодавно заявляв, що шляху назад немає.
- Ми дотримуватимемося цілей, які ми поставили
в галузі захисту довкілля. Не важливо, чи це подобається французам.
Утім, уже на початку цього тижня він сів за стіл переговорів
із "жовтими жилетами" та партіями, що приєдналися до протестів.
І судячи з усього, поступився: збільшення акцизу на пальне відтермінували.
Прісциллія не проти захисту довкілля.
Але чому платити за це повинні переважно жителі провінцій,
які залежать від автомобілів? Адже так
прірва між центром і периферією, між багатими та бідними стає ще більшою.
- Важливо, щоб президент нас почув,
щоб поставив свої рішення під питання.
Треба разом знайти рішення. Лише так ми досягнемо успіху.
Тим часом праві популісти вирішили скористатися з цієї ситуації.
Партія "Національне зібрання" Марін ле Пен приєдналася до протестів.
- Ми підтримуємо цей рух. Це саме те,
що ми критикуємо протягом багатьох років.
Такий захист довкілля штрафує людей.
Саме це і робить пан Макрон.
Він хоче, щоб автомобіль як транспорт став надто дорогим.
Тепер Прісциллія вимушена спостерігати,
як ультраправі використовують протести, які вона ініціювала
та організувала кілька місяців тому. Вже не раз
праворадикали ображали "жовті жилети",
виявляли расизм щодо водіїв із іншим кольором шкіри,
нападали на автомобілі.
- Нам не потрібні люди, які представляють ідеологію якоїсь партії.
Вони можуть брати участь у протестах як звичайні громадяни,
тому що це громадянський рух.
Але не виступати в якості представника своєї партії.
Інші партії також намагалися використовувати Прісциллію та її рух.
Але вона не йде на це. Адже зрештою
йдеться не про правих чи лівих,
а про справедливість для незаможних французів.